What Started World War I
The commonly held notion that WWI was started
out of outrage over the assassination of Archduke
Franz Ferdinand of Austria and his wife Sophie
at the hands of Serbian nationalist secret
society known as the “Black Hand” isn’t
entirely correct.
In fact, the Emperor Franz Josef himself expressed
relief over the assassination because it rid
him of an heir whom he deeply disliked.
The Emperor commented that “God will not
be mocked.
A higher power had put back the order I couldn’t
maintain.”
Indeed, it wasn’t just the Emperor who was
relieved; it was reported by an Austrian newspaper
that the general consensus among the various
political circles was that the assassination,
though a tragedy, was for the best.
As far as the Austrian people were concerned,
it was noted “The event almost failed to
make any impression whatever.
On Sunday and Monday, the crowds in Vienna
listened to music and drank wine as if nothing
had happened.”
Indeed, it took the government itself a full
three weeks to react.
As you’ll see shortly, the “treaty alliance
system” that was prevalent in Europe with
numerous treaties interconnecting the various
states was really at the heart of why what
would have been a small conflict, not noteworthy
in any way in history, escalated into one
of the bloodiest wars in human history with
over around 37 million casualties.
Somewhat ironically, the spark that set it
all off was the assassination that nobody
really cared about.
So why go to war over an assassination, if
nobody cared?
Because, while nobody seemed to much care
about the assassination itself, Austria-Hungary
had been looking for an excuse to wage a “preventative
war” against Serbia as a state in order
to weaken or destroy them so as to take back
territory in the Balkans, which had been taken
during the Balkan Wars.
They had not taken it back up to this point
because they lacked Germany’s support; without
that support, they feared Russia too much,
because of the treaty Russia had with Serbia.
With the assassination of Archduke Franz Ferdinand
and his wife on June 28th, 1914, Austria-Hungary
was able to secure the promise from Germany
that it would aid in a war with Serbia and
possibly Russia, if Russia chose to enter
the fray due to their treaty with Serbia.
It should be noted here that Austria-Hungary
did not really expect Russia to enter the
fray as they expected this to be a very small
war that would be over quickly, before Russia
would be obligated to respond.
Now with Germany’s support if Russia did
enter the fray, Austria-Hungary issued an
ultimatum to Serbia with remarkably severe
terms that Serbia would be sure to reject,
thus giving Austria-Hungary an excuse to go
launch a limited war on Serbia to reclaim
territory in the Balkans.
Surprisingly, Serbia responded relatively
well to the ultimatum, but they did dispute
a few minor clauses, which gave Austria-Hungary
the excuse they needed to go to war.
At this point, the following general series
of events happened due to a variety of existing
treaties between various nations, which escalated
this minor clash into the first “Great War”.
• Russia bound by their treaty with Serbia
decides to come to Serbia’s aid.
• Germany, with the recent treaty with Austria-Germany,
declares war on Russia.
• France, bound by an existing treaty with
Russia, now was at war with Germany by association.
Germany then invades Belgium to have easy
access to France.
• Britain, allied to France with an existing
treaty, declared war against Germany.
This was unexpected by Germany as they expected
Britain to stay out of the war, due to the
fact that the treaty with France was loosely
worded and not entirely binding.
However, Britain also had a 75 year old treaty
with Belgium.
So because of both of these treaties, they
decided to declare war on Germany.
• With Britain now warring with Germany,
Canada, India, Australia, New Zealand, and
South Africa enter the war as they were colonies
of Britain.
• Japan honored an existing treaty with
Britain and declared war on Germany.
• Austria-Hungary declared war on Japan
for declaring war on Germany.
• The U.S. tried to stay out of the war
but in 1917 decided to enter due to Germany’s
submarines hindering the United States’
commercial shipping due to the fact that the
U.S. was shipping a lot of supplies to the
Allies.
So in the end, a small quick war over a minor
land dispute got turned into a lengthy war
that was joined by powers all over the globe
due to a variety of existing treaties dating
back as much as 75 years before the war started.